Do you struggle to concentrate, to finish tasks, or feel like your brain is constantly jumping channels? It might not just be stress, it could be ADHD. More and more adults are learning that what they've been battling for years wasn't just laziness or lack of willpower, but undiagnosed ADHD. In this episode, I am joined by Dr. Cara Davey, a clinical psychologist who herself has ADHD, but also specializes in the assessment and coaching of people with ADHD. We unpack the signs, the diagnostic process, and what it's like to finally understand yourself.
你是否在集中注意力或完成任务时感到挣扎，或者觉得自己的大脑一直在不停地切换频道？这可能不仅仅是压力，它可能是注意力缺陷多动障碍（ADHD）。越来越多成年人了解到，他们多年来一直在与之抗争的不仅仅是懒惰或缺乏意志力，而是未被诊断出来的ADHD。在本期节目中，临床心理学家卡拉·戴维（Dr. Cara Davey）博士将与我一同探讨。她本人也患有ADHD，同时专门从事ADHD人群的评估和教练工作。我们将剖析这些迹象、诊断过程，以及最终能够理解自己是一种怎样的体验。
I hope you find it super useful. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne, a qualified clinical psychologist. Now, unless you've been living under a rock, you cannot have failed to have noticed the rise in people talking about ADHD and neurodiversity. That's led lots of people to consider whether that might be something which could help them to understand themselves or someone that they care about or maybe even both. I thought it was time that I met with someone who's qualified and experienced to talk us through all of these considerations, you know, about what the diagnosis is, what the assessment is, what it means about ourselves. And so I am delighted
我希望你觉得这非常有用。你好，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》播客。我是玛丽安（Dr. Marianne）博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。好了，除非你一直与世隔绝，否则你一定不会没有注意到谈论ADHD和神经多样性的人数正在增加。这导致许多人开始考虑这是否能帮助他们理解自己，或是理解他们在乎的人，甚至可能两者兼而有之。我认为是时候和一位具备资格和经验的专家见面，来为我们梳理所有这些考量了，你知道的，比如什么是诊断，什么是评估，这对我们自己意味着什么。因此，我非常高兴
to welcome Dr. Kara to the podcast. Let's dive into our conversation and I'll catch you on the other side. If you do find the content helpful, please do subscribe, follow the show, like, comment, tell everybody. I will see you very soon. I just want to welcome along our guest for today, Dr. Kara Davie. For anyone who's a regular to the podcast, if you ever hear me talk about Dr. Cara, this is she. Hi, Cara. Hi, Mary Ann.
欢迎卡拉博士来到本播客。让我们深入今天的对话，我们在节目另一端见。如果你确实觉得这些内容有帮助，请务必订阅、关注本节目、点赞、评论并告诉所有人。我们很快就会见面。我只想欢迎我们今天的嘉宾卡拉·戴维博士。对于播客的老听友来说，如果你听过我谈论卡拉博士，就是这位了。嗨，卡拉。嗨，玛丽安。
Lovely to see you. Thanks for inviting me on. So nice to have you here. And you know, you have so many interesting things I could have invited you on to talk about. And in fact, later in the year, we're to be talking about Baby Loss Awareness Week but today we're thinking about adult ADHD aren't we? Yes we are. Can you tell me why that's resonated with you if that's okay? Absolutely so, I specialize in ADHD. I was diagnosed myself as an adult about five
很高兴见到你。谢谢邀请我来。很高兴你能来。你知道，你可以聊的有趣话题太多了，我本可以邀请你来谈谈别的。事实上，今年晚些时候我们将讨论“流产意识周”（Baby Loss Awareness Week），但今天我们关注的是成人ADHD，对吧？是的，没错。能告诉我为什么这个话题能引起你的共鸣吗，如果可以的话？当然可以，我专注于ADHD领域。大约在大约五
years ago now. And I suppose, so a little bit about my kind of journey, the reason that I will come on to talk about kind of baby loss and infertility later in the year, I had a difficult fertility journey, including kind of numerous losses and a stillbirth. And around that time also became a parent. So most of my infertility was kind of secondary infertility. And around that time, noticed repeatedly kind of struggling with executive functioning type tasks. So for anyone who doesn't know what I mean by executive functioning type tasks, things like remembering, you know, things like I was forgetting my keys often and just struggling with things that weren't so much
年前，我被确诊为成人ADHD。我想，稍微谈谈我的人生旅程吧，我之所以会在今年晚些时候来谈论流产和不孕不育，是因为我经历了一段艰难的生育历程，包括多次流产和一个死产。差不多在那时，我也成为了一名母亲。所以我大部分的不孕其实是继发性不孕。在那段时间里，我注意到自己反复在执行功能类型的任务上感到挣扎。所以对于任何不知道我所说的执行功能类型任务是什么意思的人来说，就是像记忆，你知道的，比如我经常忘带钥匙，而且在处理以前并不是太大
of a problem before. And I think as someone who's worked in trauma for a long time, initially my thought was, well, of course, like there's a lot going on in terms of the infertility and the grief and trauma. So I thought probably that's what's going on. But as I did trauma work to work that through and felt really much better emotionally, it was still struggling with, you know, kind of more ADHD type tasks and that kind of, yeah, forgetting things, etc. And started to look for what else is going on here. And after kind of lots of reading and research, kind of managed to put together the dots that actually it was ADHD, and that the kind of trauma and grief had kind of turned up the symptoms of ADHD. And that although they'd always been there, I'd managed to kind of compensate and find ways around that, but actually they were
问题的事情时感到吃力。我认为，作为一个长期从事创伤研究的人，我最初的想法是，这很正常，因为在不孕不育、悲伤和创伤方面发生了很多事情。所以我以为这可能就是原因所在。但是，当我通过创伤疗愈工作解决了这些问题，并在情感上感觉好多了之后，我仍然在面对更多ADHD类型的任务时感到挣扎，比如那种健忘等等。于是我开始寻找这里面到底还发生了什么。经过大量的阅读和研究，我终于把这些点串联起来，发现实际上这就是ADHD，创伤和悲伤只是把ADHD的症状放大了。虽然这些症状一直都在，但我设法进行了补偿并找到了应对的方法，但实际上它们正
becoming much more problematic. So that's my kind of personal interest in it. And then professionally I've gone on to kind of train to assess ADHD. I also provide specific therapy and ADHD coaching to support people after diagnosis. Okay, that's really interesting. And actually, what you're kind of saying is that maybe a change in someone's personal circumstances can affect their resilience, which actually means that they're less able to cope kind of with everything that's going on and therefore dropping more balls, like rubber ones as well as glass ones and like you know just not getting done the things that are actually quite important for your functioning. Is that kind of what you mean, Cara? Yeah, I mean I don't know if I would like the word resilience as such but I think
变得越来越成问题。这就是我个人对这个话题感兴趣的原因。在专业上，我继续接受了评估ADHD的培训。我还提供专门的治疗和ADHD教练服务，在确诊后支持人们。好的，这真的很有趣。事实上，你所说的是，一个人个人环境的变化可能会影响他们的韧性，这实际上意味着他们不那么能够应付正在发生的一切，因此漏掉了更多的事情，就像丢掉橡胶球一样，也丢掉玻璃球，而且你知道的，就是没能完成那些对你的功能实际上非常重要的。卡拉，是这个意思吗？是的，我的意思是我不知道我是否喜欢“韧性”这个词本身，但我想
yes, essentially a lot of people who are diagnosed with ADHD as an adult have found ways to master cope, to function despite the kind of challenges they have. And there can be a change in circumstances that suddenly mean it exceeds your ability to juggle and cope. And suddenly the things that before you were managing to get by on it's like, oh, I've made a mistake there. Oh, I've made a mistake there. And it's like, why do I keep doing these things that I wouldn't have done before? And so I think it's to do with exceeding the capacity. There's only so long you can go on trying to function in a neurotypical way and do everything and compensate before the brain starts to say, oh, I'm not sure if this is getting a bit much. And I think personal circumstances, trauma, grief can certainly be ways that one can exceed that capacity
本质上，许多被诊断为成年期ADHD的人已经找到了掌握应对的方法，尽管他们面临挑战，但仍能正常生活。环境的变化可能会突然意味着它超出了你应付和处理的能力。突然间，以前你还能勉强应付的事情，会让你觉得：“哦，我那里犯了个错误。哦，我那里又犯了个错误。”然后你会想：“为什么我一直在做这些以前不会做的事情？”所以我认为这与超出能力有关。你试图以神经典型的方式生活并做所有事情并进行补偿的时间是有限的，直到大脑开始说：“哦，我不知道这是否有点太多了。”我认为个人环境、创伤、悲伤当然可以让人非常迅速地超出这种能力，
quite quickly and just generally parenting for lots of women too is another one that suddenly exceeds capacity. Yeah, I hear you on that one. Can you tell us how ADHD might look different in children compared to adults. Yeah, I mean, just to say around ADHD, firstly, it does vary for different people how it presents. So it's, you know, for some people, they might be diagnosed with what we call inattentive ADHD. So they're struggling with kind of attention and concentration, but actually, they don't show many signs of hyperactivity, where they're kind of struggling, the kind of classic thought of hyperactivity where they're kind of struggling,
对于许多女性来说，为人父母也是另一种突然超出能力范围的情况。是的，我完全理解。你能告诉我们，儿童时期的ADHD表现与成年期有何不同吗？是的，我的意思是，首先要说明的是，关于ADHD，它在不同人身上的表现首先是各不相同的。所以，（对于）有些人来说，他们可能被诊断为我们所说的“注意力缺陷型ADHD”（inattentive ADHD）。因此，他们正在与注意力不集中作斗争，但实际上，他们并没有表现出太多的多动迹象，他们不会像人们传统印象中的多动那样挣扎，也就是那种难以安坐或需要四处走动的情况——
the kind of classic thought of people struggling to sit still or kind of needing to move, like that's your more hyperactive and you can be combined, which is a combination of both. So firstly, when we think of children, I think the kind of old school before we knew more about how ADHD presents, we think of children who can't sit still in class or might be behaving in a way that some people might have labelled in the past as kind of naughty. So often that's how we think of it and often that's how it's kind of seen and picked up in children. By the time someone becomes an adult, if they were presenting in that way, that hyperactivity tends to be much more internalised. They've learnt ways to mask, to hide it, to...
这就是偏向多动的类型，你也可以是混合型，这是两者的结合。所以首先，当我们想到儿童时，我想在对ADHD的表现有更多了解之前的传统观念中，我们会想到在课堂上坐不安稳的儿童，或者他们的行为可能会被过去某些人贴上“调皮”标签的儿童。通常这就是我们的想法，通常这也是儿童时期被看待和发现的方式。等到一个人成年后，如果他们是以那种方式表现的，那么多动倾向往往会更加内化。他们学会了伪装、隐藏自己的方法……
If they've received, you know, the average is that someone will receive about 20,000 more kind of negative messages if someone is kind of has ADHD as a child, then an adult who doesn't have ADHD. So they are constantly told sit still, be quiet, don't do that, you're too much or too sensitive. You know, all of these comments that mean by the time someone becomes an adult, they've often refined, I need to behave in a way that makes me seem more kind of neurotypical. So it's harder sometimes when you're diagnosing an adult to be able to pick up on, okay, what's there and what's the coping strategy, whereas for children, often children act more in line with what they're experiencing and have done less of that masking. So yeah, but it will depend if someone is more inattentive or more hyperactive, what you're looking for. But yeah, as a result, normally when you're working with adults, you're seeing the fallout of what has that masking done for them? So what is the emotional impact? How has it affected their self-esteem?
如果他们曾受到过——你知道的，平均而言，如果一个孩子患有ADHD，与一个没有ADHD的成年人相比，他们会受到大约多出2万条左右的负面信息。所以他们不断被告知：坐好、安静、别那样做、你太闹腾了或者太敏感了。你知道，所有这些评论意味着，当一个人长大成人时，他们往往已经提炼出了一套行为方式，让自己看起来更像“神经典型”。因此，当你在诊断一个成年人时，有时很难分辨出哪些是原本的特质，哪些是应对策略，而对于儿童来说，儿童的行动往往更符合他们的真实体验，进行这种伪装较少。所以，是的，但这取决于一个人是更偏向注意力缺陷还是更多动，来决定你要寻找的是什么。但是，是的，因此，当你与成年人合作时，你通常看到的是这种伪装对他们造成的后续影响。那么，它带来的情绪影响是什么？它如何影响了他们的自尊？
How have they gone from perhaps over-functioning to try and mask those things to suddenly struggling to over-function? Yeah, people are trying to understand the impact that hiding their ADHD has had even if it wasn't consciously. Whereas as children there's less of that. If you can get it early on you're actually helping with the ADHD rather than the impact of it. Yeah, absolutely and I'm me think about my own school reports and they were always, Mary-Anne talks too much. Struggles to kind of do this and that.
他们是如何从可能为了试图掩饰这些事情而过度运转，突然变成陷入挣扎的？是的，人们正试图理解隐藏ADHD所产生的影响，即使这种隐藏并非出于有意识。而作为儿童，这种隐藏则较少。如果你能在早期介入，你实际上是在帮助缓解ADHD本身，而不是仅仅去应对它带来的影响。是的，绝对是这样。我想到了我自己的学校成绩单，上面总是写着：玛丽安话说得太多了。在做这方面和那方面时有困难。
But at the time, the setting wasn't the kind of the awareness really that girls could have ADHD or it wasn't quite so mainstream as it is now and how does that pan out for women? Are there differences in the way that kind of different genders would present with ADHD as an adult? I think what we know is that often women are more likely to be diagnosed with kind of inattentive ADHD, so less of that kind of hyperactivity. If they are hyperactive, it tends to be more internalised or it might show more as anxiety or kind of internal fidgeting under their desk or moving their feet where people can't see kind of. know now is that that presents differently and it's more likely that women present that way. But actually, I would say even to go further than that, I work with a lot of people
但在当时，这种环境并没有真正意识到女孩也会患有ADHD，或者它不像现在这样成为主流。这在女性身上是如何体现的呢？不同性别的人作为成年人表现出ADHD的方式是否存在差异？我们所知道的是，女性更有可能被诊断出患有注意力缺陷型ADHD，因此多动迹象较少。如果她们有多动，往往会更加内化，或者可能表现为更多的焦虑，或者在桌子底下进行内在的摸索，或者在别人看不到的地方移动双脚。我们现在所知道的是，这种表现各不相同，女性更有可能以这种方式呈现。但是，我甚至想更进一步地说，我与许多人合作过，
who are quite high functioning, who've not had diagnosis as children, but when they look back it kind of makes sense. And that's the same for men too. There are other reasons that somebody who's quite high functioning might have been missed. It's not just women who struggle with inattentive ADHD. There can be men too. There are lots of factors. But yes, typically with women, you see more of the inattentive type presentation. It's more internalized.
他们功能相当高，在童年时期没有被诊断出来，但当他们回首往事时，这一切就说得通了。男性也是如此。功能较高的人漏诊还有其他原因。不仅仅是女性在注意力缺陷型ADHD方面苦苦挣扎。男性也会有。这其中有很多因素。但是，是的，通常对于女性，你会看到更多注意力缺陷型的表现。它更加内化，
It might come out more in subtle things like friendship issues. You might see more of that kind of anxiety, as friendship issues, you might see more of that kind of anxiety as I say, as a result of that masking, they might be trying to overcompensate, be overly perfectionistic or yeah, that's more the kind of presentation you'll see in women but it's certainly not exclusive to women. And what we know with women is it's also much more affected by hormones, which is obviously something that's less of an issue for men, but in terms of the monthly cycle, in terms of pregnancy, postnatally, menopause, all of the times that women's hormones are fluctuating up and down, actually that affects ADHD symptoms in a way that is, you know, kind of less understood because a lot of the research is
它可能更多地体现在一些微妙的事情上，比如友谊问题。你可能会看到更多那种焦虑，作为我刚才所说的伪装的结果，她们可能会试图过度补偿，变得过于完美主义，或者，是的，这更多的是你在女性身上看到的表现，但这绝对不是女性所独有的。我们对女性的了解是，它受荷尔蒙的影响也大得多，这显然对男性的影响较小，但在月经周期方面、怀孕期间、产后、更年期，所有女性荷尔蒙起伏波动的时期，实际上都会以一种较少被理解的方式影响ADHD症状，因为许多研究仍然
still on men where that's not present. Thank you. And something called rejection sensitive dysphoria, RSD, is that more commonly expressed in women or does that seem to be kind of universal, do you know? I mean I've certainly worked with men who talk about RSD too. I think RSD is, yeah, for anyone who doesn't know this, finding rejection incredibly difficult and being very sensitive to that feeling of rejection. Some people argue it's part of emotional dysregulation, that people are likely to be more emotionally dysregulated. Often women express emotions more freely than men, and men have encouraged less to do so. So
集中在没有这些情况的男性身上。谢谢。还有一种叫做“拒绝敏感性 dysphoria”（RSD，拒绝敏感性紊乱）的东西，这在女性中更常见，还是说它似乎是普遍存在的，你知道吗？我的意思是，我当然也和谈论过RSD的男性合作过。我认为RSD是，是的，对于任何不知道这一点的人来说，就是觉得被拒绝极其困难，并且对这种被拒绝的感觉非常敏感。有些人认为这是情绪失调的一部分，人们更有可能出现情绪失调。女性通常比男性更自由地表达情感，而男性则被鼓励少这样做。所以
you might see that women are more likely to talk about it or express that kind of RSD, but it's not solely women at all. Again, it depends on people's experiences. And with everything ADHD can be there, but it also interacts with someone's own history. So people with ADHD might struggle with friendships, so they might make friendships very easily, but they might struggle to maintain those friendships. It's kind of a novelty, you know, they meet someone, it's all exciting, and then they move on and find a new interest, and they find a new friendship, or it's harder to sustain it because people find it more annoying that they keep talking, or you know, whatever it might be, there are things that get in the way
你可能会看到女性更有可能谈论或表达那种RSD，但这绝不仅仅是女性独有的。同样，这取决于人们的经历。对于ADHD来说，所有这些都可以存在，但它也与每个人自己的历史相互作用。患有ADHD的人可能在友谊方面苦苦挣扎，他们可能很容易建立友谊，但可能难以维持这些友谊。这有点像新鲜感，你知道的，他们遇到了某个人，一切都很兴奋，然后他们继续前进并找到了新的兴趣，他们找到了新的友谊，或者这更难以维持，因为人们会觉得他们一直说话很烦人，或者你知道的，无论可能是什么原因，有些事情会阻碍
annoying that they keep talking or you know whatever it might be there are things that get in the way of friendship issues and again it's more common but not always for women and girls to have friendship issues kind of especially in schooling you find that girls kind of often fall out more than boys do. Now if they've had lots of experiences of being rejected throughout schooling for those kind of things you're more likely to be sensitive to rejection. So there's a combination of people's life experiences as well as things that you might be prone to as a result of having kind of a neurodiverse brain. Thank you and you know I'm extra glad that we've been able to nurture and sustain our friendship since 2008 as well because it's just been a pleasure having you in my life. You know, personal, professional, I just value you, Cara. Can we think, you know,
他们一直说话很烦人，或者你知道的，不管可能是什么原因，有些事情会阻碍友谊的发展。同样，女性和女孩出现友谊问题更为常见，但并非总是如此，尤其是在学校教育中，你会发现女孩往往比男孩更容易闹翻。现在，如果她们在学校里因为这些事情经历过很多被拒绝的经历，你就会对拒绝更加敏感。因此，这里既有人生经历的组合，也有因为拥有神经多样性的大脑而容易产生的倾向。谢谢你，你知道的，我格外高兴的是，我们从2008年以来一直能够培育和维系我们的友谊，因为生命中有你陪伴真是一大乐事。无论是个人还是职业上，卡拉，我都非常珍视你。我们可以思考一下，你知道的，
when we're commonly screening for ADHD, sleep can be a big one, that basically you need to perhaps to have been problematic in the sleep criteria for that to be given the green stamp of approval in the past. Is that still given the same weight, do you know? So firstly, just to say I massively value your friendship too, before I move on to that question. Sleep is an interesting one. So sleep isn't a criteria on its own. When you're looking to diagnose ADHD, people might ask around sleep,
当我们通常对ADHD进行筛查时，睡眠是一个重要方面，基本上，你可能需要在睡眠标准上存在问题，过去才能获得绿灯批准。你知道，现在这还被赋予同等的分量吗？首先，我要说的是，在我回答那个问题之前，我也非常珍视我们的友谊。睡眠是一个有趣的话题。所以睡眠本身不是一个标准。当你想要诊断ADHD时，人们可能会询问有关睡眠的情况，
but it's not a kind of, it you're looking to diagnose ADHD, people might ask around sleep, but it's not a kind of, it doesn't have to be there. It's not an essential criteria for someone to have a diagnosis. Again, what we might see is people who are internalizing hyperactivity or kind of on the go a lot during the day or kind of holding in so busy that they're not really thinking about any worries or they've got quite a busy mind. As soon as they go quiet to go to bed at night, suddenly that's when their mind's kind of very busy and it might affect sleep. So we do see sleep issues in people with ADHD quite common. And yeah, that's where lots of people are kind of overthinking, but it's not an essential criteria. People don't have to have struggled with sleep. Sometimes you find people
但这并不是一种，它不需要存在。这不是一个人获得诊断的基本标准。同样，我们可能会看到的情况是，那些将多动内化或者在白天有很多活动，或者脑子里装了太多事情、非常忙碌以至于没有真正去思考任何担忧、或者有着相当繁忙的大脑的人。一旦他们安静下来准备晚上上床睡觉，突然间他们的脑子就会变得非常活跃，这可能会影响睡眠。因此，我们在ADHD患者身上确实很常见到睡眠问题。是的，这也是许多人过度思考的地方，但这不是一个基本标准。人们不必经历过睡眠困难。有时你会发现人们
are the opposite where they are so busy in the day and they're so active and they're using exercise and things to manage kind of hyperactivity type symptoms that they just crash out instantly and they're like, oh no, I have no issues at all. I would say I've seen quite a few people where there's an overlap between neurodiversity and sleep apnea as well, where people were actually struggling to get the right quality and sleep apnea as well, where people were actually struggling to get the right quality of sleep and kind of waking. And so yeah, there's some questions at the moment and kind of research around whether there's any link between that. But certainly if there are sleep apnea symptoms, that's likely to make ADHD symptoms worse and kind of exacerbate that. We know that poor sleep
恰恰相反，他们在白天非常忙碌、非常活跃，他们通过锻炼和其他方式来控制类似多动的症状，以至于他们倒头就睡，并且会说：“哦，不，我一点问题都没有。”我想说的是，我见过相当多的人，在神经多样性和睡眠呼吸暂停之间也存在重叠，这些人实际上在努力获得高质量的睡眠，并且存在睡眠呼吸暂停和惊醒的情况。所以，是的，目前有一些关于这之间是否存在任何联系的问题和研究。但可以肯定的是，如果存在睡眠呼吸暂停的症状，那很可能会使ADHD症状恶化并加剧这种情况。我们知道，睡眠质量差
doesn't help with ADHD symptoms. Very interesting. And I guess also, it really depends how people have been sleep trained or not in their younger years as to whether they are good sleepers or not, but what distress that has cost them to kind of get there. Yeah, just talking to you has made me think, oh, I really miss the sleep of my late 20s, my mid to late 20s, because my sleep patterns are certainly not like that anymore. And it's not for a lack of trying. Yeah, absolutely. It's so much harder.
对ADHD症状毫无帮助。非常有趣。我想这也很大程度上取决于人们在年幼时是否接受过睡眠训练，来决定他们是否是睡眠好的人，但这让他们付出了多少痛苦才达到那种状态。是的，跟你聊天让我想起：“哦，我真的很怀念我二十多岁快结束时、二十五六岁时的睡眠，因为我的睡眠模式现在肯定不像那样了。”这绝对不是因为我没有努力。是的，绝对是这样。难太多了。
Yeah, absolutely. Can we think then about what an adult ADHD assessment might look like? A great robust one, I guess. Let's give that as an example. Yeah, and I think it's worth, as you kind of mentioned, a kind of robust one. There are a range of different kind of qualities of ADHD assessment out there from people who are giving a diagnosis quite quickly, and, you know, kind of that might be cheaper as a result of that to people who are doing much more in-depth assessments. I think sometimes people can be attracted to the quick, cheaper assessment because people with ADHD have often researched things a lot
是的，绝对是这样。那么，我们可以思考一下成人ADHD的评估是什么样的吗？我想象一个非常扎实的评估。让我们以此为例。是的，我认为正如你所提到的，一个扎实的评估是值得拥有的。市面上存在各种不同质量的ADHD评估，从那些能够非常快地给出诊断的人（你知道的，这可能因此更便宜），到那些进行更深入评估的人。我认为有时人们会被快速、便宜的评估所吸引，因为患有ADHD的人通常已经对事情进行了大量研究，并且会说：“我早就知道我有这个病了，我只是想要一张纸或者一些官方的东西，因为它能帮助我理解我的人生并理清头绪。”所以有时人们会被吸引去这样做。我认为这样做的一个缺点是，有时这些更便宜的评估实际上并不是由获准进行评估的人进行的。所以它们可能实际上并不符合NICE（英国国家健康与照顾卓越研究院）指南的标准。所以有时人们在接受评估。因此，如果他们想获得药物治疗，例如，如果
and go, I already know that I've got it, I just want the piece of paper or something official because it helps me to understand my life and to make sense of things. So sometimes people will be drawn to that. I think the downside of that is that sometimes these cheaper assessments are not being actually done by people who are approved to do an assessment. So they might not actually meet the nice guidelines kind of criteria. So sometimes people are being assessed. And as a result, if they wanted to access medication, for example, if
他们没有接受过合适人员的评估，他们就无法获得；但除此之外，有时这些较短的评估往往是一份报告被反复使用，它们不是个性化的。我认为一个好的评估不仅应该使用诊断访谈，你知道的，也就是贯穿各种问题并与某人一起探讨的访谈，去审视不同的症状及其例子。它还应该与他们生活中的某个人交谈，理想情况下是父母，如果不行，则是其他能够谈论他们注意到什么以及他们在童年时期如何表现的人。但它还应该着眼于更广泛的因素，还有什么在其中发挥作用？正如我们所说，他们的生活中经历过创伤吗？
they've not been assessed by the right person, they can't but also they tend to be sometimes these shorter assessments can be a kind of the same report is used again and again and they're not personalised and I think a good assessment should not only use the kind of diagnostic interview you know that we that goes through the kind of questions and explores with someone the kind of looking at the different symptoms and examples of that. It should also speak to somebody within their ideally a parent, but if not somebody else that can speak to kind of how, what they notice and how they're presented as a child. But it should also look at the wider kind of factor, what else is playing a part in this? So as we've said, has there been trauma in their life?
童年时期是否经历过其他艰难的生活事件？是否存在可能起到作用或有贡献的医疗问题？这有一大堆因素。这应该是一个真正的整体性评估。我认为这不仅是为了回答“是否有ADHD”这个问题。它是为了回答下一个问题：“好吧，如果我有ADHD，我该怎么做，什么能帮助我？”我认为有太多人从不够扎实、不够全面、不够整体的评估中走出来时，得到的只是：“你可以尝试药物治疗，或者你可以尝试教练服务”，然后就结束了。然而事实上，根本没有关注到：对你来说，看起来是
Had there been other difficult life events as a child? Are there medical issues that might be playing a part or contributing? And there's a whole host. It should be a kind of real holistic assessment. And I think that's not just to answer the question of is ADHD there or not. It's to answer the next question of, okay, so if I have ADHD, what do I do about it and what would help me? And I think so many people come out of an assessment that's less robust and kind of less comprehensive and less holistic with, you know, kind of, you can try medication or you can try coaching or, and that's it. Whereas actually, there's no focus on, okay, for you, it looks like
这些、这些、这些因素在起作用，如果你想得到帮助，这可能会有所帮助。或者根本没有将个性化的治疗计划拼凑在一起来帮助这个人，因为仅仅因为人们有共同的ADHD特征，并不意味着他们会从完全相同的治疗和建议中受益。是的，我想他们几乎可以像在糖果店里挑选和混合一样，在不同时期选择不同的东西。例如，可能发生的情况是，你现在实际上并不想尝试药物治疗。但这可能是你将来会考虑的事情，或者反过来，你可能会想：“实际上，我真的很想
this, this, this and this are contributing, you know, this might help if you want to help with that. Or there's no kind of putting together of a personalised kind of treatment plan of what would help that person because just because people have ADHD traits in common doesn't mean they will benefit from exactly the same treatments and recommendations. Yeah, I guess that they might almost like pick and mix choose different things at different times. So it might be, for example, that you actually don't want to try medication right now. But it might be something that you would consider in future or the other way around, you might be like, actually, I would really like to
体验一下减少噪音、减少干扰、减少干扰是怎样的感觉，能够毫无干扰地完成一项任务，而不会被其他任务或令人兴奋或新奇的事情所分心。”仅仅去体验一下，我认为这是一个非常好的比喻：如果你有一道栅栏，你需要越过栅栏去看风景，你某种程度上需要思考你需要什么步骤来让自己达到和别人一样的高度，从而能够以同样的方式完成任务。而实际上，你要付出比别人多得多的努力才能达到和别人一样的表现。你知道，这公平吗？对自己这样公平吗？这有同理心吗？而且，你知道，我有时与客户合作的经验是，他们会说：“实际上，哦，当我服用药物时，实际上我可以
experience perhaps what it is like to have less noise, to have less distractions, to have less distractions, to be able to perhaps get through a task without being distracted by other tasks or exciting or novel things to do. Just to experience, I think it was a really nice idea of kind of if you've got a fence and you need to look over the fence, you kind of need to think about what steps you need to get yourself to be the same height as somebody else, to be able to perform kind of the same way in the task. And actually, it's taking you all that much more effort to get the same performance as somebody else. You know, is that fair? Is that kind to yourself? Is that compassionate? And, you know, my experience of working with clients sometimes is that they're like, actually, oh, when I take medication, actually, I can
更加轻而易举地达到我自己设定的目标。”但这是一个个人选择，对吧？并不是说你做完ADHD评估就必须、必须吃药。这始终是一个个人选择。绝对是的。是的，正如你所说，有些人想尝试，有些人不想尝试，有些人因为某些健康原因无法尝试，比如你可能有心脏病或其他不适合的情况。你知道，这是人们可能会倾向于选择的一种方式，他们可能想立即尝试或在未来尝试。但
meet the targets that I would set for myself a whole heap easier, but it is a personal choice, isn't it? It's not like you're going to get an ADHD assessment and you must, must have medication. It's always a personal choice. Absolutely. Yeah, As you said, some people want to try it, some people don't want to try it, some people can't because of certain health things, like you might be heart conditions or things that exclude it. You know, it's a choice that someone might be drawn towards and they might, you know, kind of want to immediately or in the future. But
同样地，还有许多其他选择也可以提供帮助，无论是治疗、教练、生活方式因素的改变、设备和工具，还是……你知道的，我在ADHD教练辅导中非常喜欢做的一件事，就是试图找出对你来说阻碍是什么，而且因人而异。你可能会有五个人都来对我说：“我正在为拖延症苦恼”，而你可能会说：“好吧，有什么策略可以帮助解决这个问题呢？”但实际上，每个人苦恼的原因可能截然不同。是的，他们都有ADHD，但其中一个人的阻碍是情绪上的，另一个人的阻碍与创伤有关，还有一个人的阻碍实际上是他们有
likewise, there are many other options too that that can help whether that be, you know, therapy, whether it be coaching, whether it be changes to lifestyle factors, whether it be kind of equipment and things, whether it's, you know, one of the things I really like doing with people in ADHD coaching is trying to find out what is the block for you, and it will vary. You could have five people who all come and say I'm struggling with procrastination and you might say okay what are the strategies to help with that but actually the reason that each person is struggling might be quite different. Yes they have ADHD but one is finding it you know the block is emotional, one the block is to do with trauma, one is the block is actually they've got
太多事情要做，完全不堪重负。所以可能会有一大堆不同的原因，一个人可能只需要把任务分解或者改变他们的环境，所以为什么有人会在同一件事情上挣扎，有各种各样不同的原因。我认为和某人一起探讨这一点真的很好。你可以在网上谷歌你喜欢的所有策略，但对你来说具体的问题是什么，我们如何能帮你克服它？我认为这要个性化得多。而且，是的，药物可能是其中的一部分，但可能并不需要，也许只需要有人去理解并带你走过这个过程。对我来说，你知道，我想你和我过去讨论过，我们认为我可能确实符合
too much to do and they're completely overwhelmed. Or so there might be a whole host of different reasons one just needs to break the task down or change their environment or so there's a whole host of different reasons why someone might be struggling with the same thing. And I think that's really nice to look at with someone. You can Google all the strategies you like, you know, kind of online, but what is specifically the issue for you and how can we help you move through it, which I think is so much more personalized. And yeah, medication may be a part of that, but it might not need to be, it might just be someone understanding and walking you through that. For me, you know, I think you and I have discussed in the past that we think I probably do fulfill
标准，但我实际上从未做过ADHD评估。对我来说，实际上建立结构真的很有帮助。所以，你知道，我会回想起我年轻的时候，我妈妈会把从烘干柜里拿出来的所有洗好的衣服放在我的床上。然后有时这些衣服最终会掉到地上去，会被塞进橱柜里，完全没有任何秩序。而我实际需要的，可能是有人
criteria, but I've never actually got assessed yet for ADHD. For me, actually having structure really helps. So I you know, I find myself thinking back to when I was younger, and my mum would put all the washing on my bed that kind of come out of the airing cupboard or whatever. And it would then sometimes end up on the floor, it would kind of be shoved in cupboards, like there was no order to that. And actually what I needed was probably someone
进来和我一起坐着，和我一起做，或者坐着，实际上现在是把你的衣服收起来的时候了。你能在睡觉前把衣服收起来吗？你知道，或者实际上我刚把你的衣服拿出来，去把它收好。等我们做完那个，我们就可以做这个了。睡觉，你知道，或者其实我刚把你的衣服拿出来，去把它收好。等我们做完那个，我们就可以做这个了。
to come in and sit with me and do it with me, or sit and kind of, actually now it's time to put your washing away. Could you put your washing away before you go to bed? You know, or actually I've just put your washing out, go and put that away. And then when we've done that, we can do this. bed, you know, or actually I've just put your washing out, go and put that away. And then when we've done that, we can do this.
然而，如果没有明确的结构，有人可能会听着觉得：“你当然需要在睡觉前把衣服收起来啊。”但如果我已经上床睡觉了而且精疲力竭，我才不想做那个。我只想把衣服扔在地板上。是的，直到现在，我想起考A-level（英国高级程度考试）的时候，实际上我做得一直很好，直到我考A-level时，没有了GCSE（普通中等教育证书）老师那种坚实的基础和督促，对我来说我有了太多的自由，而我所需要的是有人对我说：“其实你需要去读那本书，玛丽安，然后我要一份总结。”因为那才会真正起到监督作用，让我负起责任来，而
Like, whereas if there's not like clear structures, someone might be listening to thinking, of course you need to put your washing away before you go to bed. But like if I've got into bed and I'm exhausted, I don't want to do that. I just want to put that on the floor. And yes, still now, I think thinking about to A levels, actually, I was doing really well until I got to A levels and without kind of the strong foundations and the accountability of GCSE teachers, for me, I had too much freedom and what I needed was someone to say actually you need to you need to read that book, Marianne, and then I want a summary because that would have really held me accountable in a way that
我自己似乎做不到这一点，结果我在A-level中只得了三个C和一个D，但我确实认为我的能力远不止于此。所以直到现在，我都必须对自己进行严格的监督。我使用Trello（项目管理软件）来做到这一点。我看着一项任务由哪些组成部分构成，并尽量不让所有的任务压垮我，而是把它分解成更小的部分，然后完成它们，并给自己设定截止日期。还记得我们在2020年9月在一个月内出版了一本书吗？实际上，对许多人来说，那会像是“一个月出一本书”一样。但对我和你来说，我们当时觉得：“太棒了，有一个固定的时间段，最后我们能产出一个成果。我们上吧！我们上吧！”所以，是的，直到
I just didn't seem to be able to do for myself to the extent where I got three Cs and a D at A level, but I do think that I was capable of far more. So still now, I have to hold myself quite accountable. I use Trello for that. I look at what the component parts of a task are and try not to let all of the tasks overwhelm me, but to kind of break it down into smaller bits and get those done and kind of give myself deadlines. Do you remember when we published a book in a month in September 2020. And actually, for many people, that would be like a book in a month. But for me and you, we were like, amazing, a fixed period of time where we'll get a product at the end. Let's go. Let's go. So yeah, still
现在，我还是会想，好吧，我希望在那个时间之前完成它。那么为了让这成为可能，我需要做哪些倒推的步骤呢？是的，绝对是这样。这种督促责任非常重要，还有那种——正如你所说的那样——当我们做那个时，我本来想说比赛，其实并不是比赛，但就像：“好，让我们俩看看我们是否能在9月份的一个月里写出一本书。”对我们俩来说，有一种竞争性的、新奇的、兴奋的、感兴趣的元素，实际上，如果很难有动力去做一项任务，那么能有一个人和你一起做就太好了，而且还要有那种竞争的元素，那种：“哦，在结束的时候，我们要聊聊，你做到了吗？”或者，你知道的，所以这就产生了一种动力，而这种动力在
now, I'll try to think, well, I want that done by that time. So what are my kind of backward steps that I need to do to make that possible? Yeah, absolutely. It's so important that accountability, but also the kind of, as you were talking, like when we did that kind of, I was going to say competition, it wasn't really a competition, but like, yes, let's both see if we can write a book in the month of September. Like for both of us, there's that kind of competitive novel, excitement kind of interest, like actually, if it's harder to get motivated to do a task, then great to have someone to do it with, but also to have that bit of kind of competitive element, that kind of, oh, at the end of it, you know, we're going to have a conversation, did you manage it? Or, you know, so it creates that kind of motivation that might not be there so much
内心深处可能并没有那么多。而且你关于结构的看法是对的。我认为这也是我们在评估中看到的一些差异，介于那些更符合注意力缺陷亚型的人和那些更符合多动元素、更偏向混合表现的人之间：通常那些混合表现的人，尽管多动症患者知道结构会有所帮助，但他们就是无法建立起结构。或者如果他们建立起来了，它也只是短暂存在的，然后他们突然忘记了这个系统的存在，或者他们已经转向了别的事情。他们往往真的、真的为此苦恼。而那些注意力缺陷型的人——我要说的是，以我的经验来看，注意力缺陷型往往与那些有时既是注意力缺陷又是自闭症的人重叠——他们通常设法找到了结构和组织，并且知道这对于控制某些ADHD的无序或混乱状态真的很有帮助，因此，你知道的，他们能够坚持下去，或者如果它与一个也有自闭症特征的人结合在一起，有时自闭症会渴望更多的结构、秩序、组织，这有助于真正将其控制住，这就是为什么人们通常直到晚些时候才表现出来，或者表现得有所不同。所以，是的，秩序、组织、结构对ADHD真的很重要，但有时无论人们如何尝试，或者无论他们多么频繁地使用这些系统，他们就是无法建立起来。再次强调，这就是为什么观察这个人的阻碍是什么、为什么会这样、他们是否需要为多动寻找另一个宣泄口、或者他们是否需要外部提醒、是否需要另一个人来监督，会如此有帮助。
kind of internally. And you're right around structure. And I think this is sometimes one of the differences we see in assessments between people who are more kind of fit more with that inattentive subtype and those who fit more with the kind of the hyperactivity element, the more kind of combined presentation, is that often people with that combined presentation, the hyperactivity as much as they know structure would help, they just cannot get it in place. Or if they do, it's in place momentarily, and then they've suddenly forgotten the system even existed, or they've kind of moved on. And they often really, really struggle with that. Whereas those with inattentive, and I would say that inattentive often, in my experience, overlaps with people who are also some of the time that inattentive is actually people who are autistic as well as ADHD, then often they have managed to find structure in an organization and they know that it's really helpful for keeping some of that ADHD disorganization or kind of chaos in check and therefore, you know, they're able to stick with that or if it is in with someone who's got autistic traits as well, sometimes the kind of
阻碍他们的到底是什么？因为这对某些人来说比对其他人更难付诸行动。是的，绝对是这样。而且我认为作为一个十几岁甚至二十多岁的年轻人，我也没有意识到体育锻炼和活动会如何真正帮助我，我不知道，让我达到最佳状态。体育锻炼对我来说总是感觉像是一种惩罚，就像是逼你去做的事情。当然，当我还在上学时，我被迫穿着一条巨大的红色紧身短裤、两侧带有白色条纹的衣服去上体育课。所以那也是一种羞辱。任何在80年代和90年代上过学的人都会说：“哦，是的，我记得那些紧身短裤。”但那绝不是
autism craves more of that structure, order, organisation, and that helps to really keep it in check, which is why often people don't present until maybe later or they present differently. So yes, order and organisation structure is really important for ADHD, but sometimes people can't get it no matter how much they try or no matter how much they use those systems. And again, that's why it's really helpful to look at what is the block for this person or why, or do they need another outlet for the hyperactivity or do they need external reminders? Do they need another person for accountability?
我选择的事情，那不是在尊重我的身体并且我期待去做的事情。我知道我们对运动有不同的经历，因为我觉得你年轻时非常活跃。我从来没有过那种经历，我想也许是因为我也有一些共济失调倾向（dyspraxic tendencies），玛丽安这个不擅长，那个不擅长，那个也不擅长。你知道的，我妈妈从来不想和我打网球，因为我很烂，而我也觉得自己很差劲。我想直到2020年左右，我才突然有了更多在家的时间，我开始跑步，然后我开始进行力量训练，并且从那以后一直坚持到现在。这真的，
Like, what is getting in the way? Because that will be harder for some people to action than others. Yeah, absolutely. And I think also I didn't realise as a teenager, even as someone in my twenties, how physical exercise and activity would really help me to, I don't know, to optimally thrive. It always felt like a punishment exercise to me, like something that you made to do. And certainly when I was at school, I was made to do it in a pair of red massive briefs with white stripes down the side. So it was humiliating as well. Anyone that went to school in the 80s and 90s would be like, oh yeah, I remember those briefs. But it was never
你知道的，我认为，尤其是当我因父亲去世而悲伤时，天哪，运动对我会非常有帮助，卡拉。但真的只有当我们开始了解我们的身体和心灵如何以最佳方式运作时，它才能，我不知道，以一种不同的方式让你理解你自己，我想。但我再次认为这真的很重要，那就是患有ADHD的人，也就是神经多样性，通常人们不仅仅有一种类型的神经多样性——患有ADHD的人有共济失调倾向并不是不常见的，如果你有那些被告知你很糟糕的经历，或者你曾在某一所学校里被迫做每一种类型的运动，
something that I was choosing, that I was, you know, honouring my body and looking forward to doing. And I know we've had different experiences of exercise, because I think you were very active when you were younger. I just, I'd never had that, I think perhaps because I've got kind of maybe some dyspraxic tendencies as well. Marianne is not very good at this, she's not very good at that, she's not very good at that. You know, my mum didn't ever want to play tennis with me because I was rubbish and poor me. And I think it's only really probably 2020 really that I suddenly had more time at home and I started running and then I started strength training and it's
而实际上可能十种被强迫做的运动中你只喜欢其中一种。许多人随后离开时的感觉是：“哦，我不喜欢运动，这让我反感，它与更艰难的经历有关。”但如果你能找到动力：“啊，我可能讨厌很多运动，但我真的很喜欢舞蹈”，或者你能找到你真正喜欢的那唯一的一件事情，那么对许多人来说，是的，这是一个非常、非常好的宣泄口。这对身体健康很有好处。它有利于引导多动。有时我会对某人进行ADHD评估，他们会说：“哦，不，我小时候没有任何多动现象。”然后他们会开始列举他们在放学后参加的所有俱乐部。他们会说：“我加入了橄榄球俱乐部，我加入了足球俱乐部，我加入了无网篮球俱乐部，你知道的……”他们列举了
gone from there and that really, you know, I think, especially when I was grieving with my dad, God, exercise would have been so helpful to me, Kara. But it's only really when we begin to learn the way that our bodies and our minds work best that it, I don't know, it can kind of give you a different way of understanding yourself, I think. But again I think that's really important is that people with ADHD, you know neurodiversity, often people don't just have one type of neurodiversity like it's not uncommon for people with ADHD to have dyspraxic tendencies and if you have those experiences of being told you're rubbish or you're you know you have been in a school that makes you do every single type of exercise and
从那之后就消失了，真的，你知道，我认为，特别是当我和父亲一起悲伤时，上帝，运动对我会非常有帮助，卡拉。但真的只有当我们开始了解我们的身体和大脑如何以最佳方式运作时，它，我不知道，它会以一种不同的方式让你理解自己，我认为。但同样我认为非常重要的是，患有多动症（ADHD）的人，你知道神经多样性，人们往往不只有一种类型的神经多样性，就像患有多动症的人有动作笨拙倾向并不是不常见的一样，如果你有过被告知你很逊或者你知道你曾在一所让你做每一种运动的学校里的经历，并且
actually maybe you only enjoy one out of the ten you've been forced to do. A lot of people then come away feeling like, oh, I don't like exercise, it's aversive, it's related to more difficult experiences. But if you can find the motivation, ah, I may hate a lot of sport, but I really enjoy dance, or you can find the one thing that you do enjoy, then a lot of people, yeah, it's a really, really helpful outlet. And it's great for physical well-being. It's good for channeling hyperactivity. And sometimes I will do an ADHD assessment with someone and they'll say, oh, no, I didn't have any hyperactivity as a child. And they'll go to list every club that they did after school. And they're like, I was in the rugby club, I was in the football club, I was in the network club, you know, and they list
实际上也许你只喜欢被强迫做的十种运动中的一种。许多人离开时会觉得，哦，我不喜欢运动，它令人反感，它与更困难的经历有关。但如果你能找到动力，啊，我可能讨厌很多运动，但我真的很喜欢舞蹈，或者你能找到那件你确实喜欢的运动，那么很多人，是的，这是一个非常非常有帮助的发泄方式。而且这对身体健康很好。它有利于引导过度活跃。有时我会和某人一起做一个多动症评估，他们会说，哦，不，我小时候没有任何过度活跃。然后他们会列出放学后参加的每一个俱乐部。他们会说，我在橄榄球俱乐部，我在足球俱乐部，我在无挡板篮球俱乐部，你知道，他们列举了
everything that they did. And I was like, it was being channeled elsewhere, like no wonder it didn't show in other ways, because it was, you know, kind of really being channeled. But yeah, it is really important to find the exercise that lights you up. And that's the same with ADHD generally, find something you're good at and you will find something you enjoy, and you will become good at it, like find your passion, and you will absolutely thrive in it. And you know, as you say, if you've got ADHD traits, you're so good at what you're doing, you found your zone of genius, you found the thing you love, and you you know, kind of throw yourself in it. And you know, we can see the results, you know, as a result of that that if you were in a job you didn't enjoy you probably wouldn't be you know kind of presenting and as productive and able to do things in the way that you are. Yeah I think if when I've been in jobs that I don't enjoy I create extracurricular responsibilities for myself so I don't have to do the job. So I think just before we met, I was working for Argos head office, and I really enjoyed my colleagues.
他们所做的一切。当时我就觉得，这些精力被引导到别的地方去了，难怪它不会以其他方式表现出来，因为它，你知道的，确实在被引导着。不过，是的，找到能点燃你热情的运动真的很重要。对于一般的多动症（ADHD）也是如此，找到你擅长的事，你就会发现你喜欢的事，然后你就会擅长它，比如找到你的热爱，你绝对会在其中蓬勃发展。你知道的，正如你所说，如果你有ADHD的特质，你就会非常擅长你正在做的事，你找到了你的天赋区，你找到了你热爱的事物，并且你，你知道的，全身心投入其中。而且你知道的，我们可以看到结果，作为其中的结果，如果你在一份不喜欢的工作中，你可能就不会，你知道的，以你现在的方式进行展示、保持高产并能够胜任各项工作。是的，我认为如果当我处于不喜欢的工作中时，我会为自己创造一些课外责任，这样我就不用去做那份工作了。所以我想在我们见面之前，我曾在Argos总部工作，我真的很喜欢我的同事们。
We had such a great time. It was a really nice team, but I was really quite bored of logging in at 9 a.m., logging out at 5 p.m., and taking customer service calls. And so I could log myself out of the system and not be accountable. I would take on Excel spreadsheet duties to look at team performance and stuff, because then my data would be completely skewed and it would be useless to anybody. But yeah, having something extra to keep myself busy
我们度过了一段非常美好的时光。这是一个非常棒的团队，但我真的对上午9点打卡上班、下午5点打卡下班以及接听客服电话感到相当厌烦。所以为了能够把自己的系统状态登出且不用承担责任，我会主动承担Excel电子表格的职责来查看团队绩效之类的工作，因为这样我的数据就会完全被扭曲，对任何人来说都毫无用处。但是，是的，弄点额外的事情来让自己保持忙碌
in quite a mundane job, really, really because it was I guess in terms of stimulation I needed more I needed more like I needed other stuff to be going on under the desk so that I could sit still in this really boring repetitive role I can still say it good afternoon store support Marianne speaking how can I help Like sometimes when I go to pick up the phone, that still wants to come out. It wasn't enough. I needed more. Yeah, absolutely. And again, that's not uncommon. The ADHD brain is often moving quickly. There's lots going through your mind and doing something mundane isn't enough. It will be looking for more than that. And so yeah, I mean, it's helpful that you were able to create ways to stay in that. But, you know, that's what you might see in the classroom
在这样一份相当枯燥的工作中，真的，真的是因为我猜在刺激感方面我需要更多，我需要更多，就像我需要桌子底下还有其他事情在进行，这样我才能在这个非常无聊、重复的岗位上坐得住。我依然能说得很好：“下午好，商店支持部，玛丽安为您服务，请问有什么可以帮您？”有时候当我去接电话时，那句话还是想脱口而出。这还不够。我需要更多。是的，完全如此。再说一次，这并不罕见。ADHD的大脑通常运转很快。有很多想法在你的脑海中闪过，仅仅做一些单调的工作是不够的。它会寻找超越这些的东西。所以，是的，我的意思是，你能创造方法让自己留在那里面是很有帮助的，但是，你知道的，这就是你在教室里可能会看到的现象：
with the child who's always doodling or the, you know, the child who looks like they're not listening because they're, you know, kind of doodling, writing, drawing, whatever, they're distracted by something, actually, they're probably looking for more stimulation, because it's not enough and their brain is kind of craving more. So yeah that's not uncommon. And sometimes that is treated negatively as well, you know, always fiddling with pounds, always rocking on a chair, you know, never seems to be paying attention, you know, staring out the window looking at this, doing that. Whereas in actual fact they may still be able to tune into exactly what you're saying but they're
那个总是喜欢涂鸦的孩子，或者，你知道的，看起来没在听讲的孩子，因为他们，你知道的，在涂鸦、写字、画画、做别的什么，他们被某些东西分散了注意力，实际上，他们可能是在寻求更多的刺激，因为这还不够，他们的大脑在渴望更多。所以，是的，这并不罕见。有时这种行为也会被负面看待，你知道的，总是摆弄铅笔，总是在椅子上摇晃，你知道的，从来不像是在专心听讲，你知道的，盯着窗外看这看那。而事实上，他们可能仍然能够准确捕捉到你在说什么，但他们
just, you know, doing other things as well so that they can, I don't know, show you respect. So they can pay attention, but they need more. I think when we're looking at schools, for example, and I'm not talking about children now, but what behaviors are exhibited when sitting still is expected? And I think it's just useful as a question for all of us to think about when I need to sit still, am I right with that? You know, do I need to do other things?
只是，你知道的，同时也做着别的事情，这样他们才能，我不知道，向你表示尊重。这样他们才能集中注意力，但他们需要更多。我认为当我们审视学校时，举个例子，我指的现在不是孩子，而是当被要求坐着不动时，会表现出什么行为？我认为这作为一个问题对我们所有人都很有用：当需要坐着不动时，我这样做好吗？你知道的，我需要做别的事情吗？
Do I need to sit like this or sit in constrained ways or, you know, rock or fiddle, a little thing that I fiddle with off the front of my diary here sometimes. Yeah, like just having a little look at what it takes for you to show up in the world. Absolutely. And I think that's the thing, you know, thinking about children, but also adults in the workplace, actually, the more someone is forced to do it, the neurotypical way or like trying to get someone to sit still, be quiet, do things in line with something that doesn't fit with them, the more you're going to see a child who struggles and often then a child might end up being labelled as naughty or difficult or someone in the workplace might be considered kind of difficult when
我需要这样坐着，还是以受约束的方式坐着，或者，你知道的，摇晃或摆弄小物件——我有时会摆弄我日记本封面上的一个小东西。是的，就像稍微观察一下，你需要付出什么才能在这个世界上展露自我。绝对的。我认为这就是关键所在，你知道的，不仅要考虑孩子，还要考虑职场中的成年人，实际上，越是强迫某人以神经典型的方式去做，或者试图让人坐着不动、安静、按某种不适合他们的方式做事，你就会看到越多苦苦挣扎的孩子，通常接着这个孩子可能会被贴上淘气或难缠的标签，或者职场中的某个人可能会被认为有点难对付，然而
actually they're just trying to conform to standards that don't fit and don't work for them, rather than being able to adjust and think, ah, what does someone need? Children often in the classroom, it might be like, right, can they do a few laps of the playground because they need to burn off a bit of energy before they're able to then sit still and to be able to listen. So yeah, I think that's really important to think about accommodations if you want someone to be able to thrive rather than labelling them as, you know, kind of naughty or not doing what they're told, as if it's a kind of conscious choice. Absolutely, yes.
实际上，他们只是在试图适应那些不适合他们、对他们不起作用的标准，而不是去调整并思考：啊，这个人需要什么？教室里的孩子们通常可能会觉得，好，他们能不能在操场上跑上几圈，因为他们需要先消耗掉一些精力，然后才能坐下来听讲？所以，是的，我认为如果你想让一个人蓬勃发展，考虑做出调整（住宿/便利措施）真的非常重要，而不是给他们贴上，你知道的，淘气或不听话的标签，好像这是一种有意识的选择一样。绝对是的。
Can we think about what people's options might be if they did want to explore an ADHD diagnosis? I'm guessing most areas of the country will have some sort of NHS provision, is there a right to choose pathway and then of course private options as well. Yeah so if you are considering an ADHD assessment for you or for your child the first step if you want to go down a kind of NHS route would be to contact your GP surgery. Most GPs will ask you to fill in, there are different questionnaires depending on if it's an adult or child and different practices have a different one. So check with your GP, but they normally do like a screening questionnaire to look at, does it look like there are symptoms present?
我们能思考一下，如果人们真的想探索ADHD诊断，他们可能会有什么选择吗？我猜该国的大多数地区都会有某种国民医疗服务体系（NHS）的医疗资源，是否存在“选择权”（Right to Choose）途径，当然还有私立途径。是的，所以如果你正在为你自己或你的孩子考虑ADHD评估，如果你想走NHS路线，第一步是联系你的全科医生（GP）诊所。大多数GP会让你填写问卷，根据是成年人还是儿童会有不同的问卷，不同的诊所也有不同的问卷。所以向你的GP确认，但他们通常会做一个筛查问卷，来看看是否有症状存在？
And then you can be referred for a assessment in your kind of local NHS team. As long as they feel you kind of meet the criteria. In some areas of the country, the wait is about five years for that. It varies depending on where you are, but actually the waits for NHS assessments are quite big at the moment. Now we know more and more about how it presents and more and more adults are looking back and realising that they've always had it. So, yeah, they're quite long wait lists. There is a right to choose pathway, as you mentioned, and that's the same for children as well, which is you can choose a provider that's a private provider that is funded by the NHS. So there will be some private options.
然后你就可以被转诊到你当地的NHS团队进行评估。前提是他们觉得你符合标准。在该国的某些地区，排队等待这个需要大约五年时间。这取决于你在哪里，但实际上目前NHS评估的等待时间相当长。现在我们对它的表现形式有了越来越多的了解，越来越多的成年人回过头来意识到他们一直都有这个情况。所以，是的，等待名单相当长。正如你所提到的，存在“选择权”途径，儿童也是如此，这意味着你可以选择一个由NHS资助的私立医疗提供者。所以会有一些私立的选择。
So it's worth asking your GP surgery. They might say, okay, there's only a two-year wait list instead of a five-year on right to choose. Some areas it's quite fast, some areas it's not. It is a real postcode lottery. So you can go down the right to choose kind of option. Again, if you think a child might have autistic traits as well as ADHD, you might want to look carefully at the providers that they give you a choice of, because some will do both and some won't. So you might find that you pick a provider and actually they
因此，去问问你的GP诊所是值得的。他们可能会说，好吧，通过“选择权”途径只需要等待两年，而不是五年。有些地区相当快，有些地区则不然。这确实像是一场看邮政编码的运气彩票。所以你可以选择“选择权”这种途径。同样，如果你认为孩子除了ADHD之外可能还有自闭症特质，你可能需要仔细查看他们供你选择的提供者，因为有些机构两者都做，有些则不做。所以你可能会发现，你挑选了一个提供者，但实际上他们
don't have a full understanding of, say, autism and that affects how they feel about the assessments, that's something to look at. And then some people will say actually the wait is too long, my child needs to have an assessment before that. For example, I think you need to try and remember, I think it's two years before someone's GCSEs they have to have a diagnosis in place to have any accommodations in their GCSE exams. So for some people they might notice tendencies in their child, the child might be struggling and the wait list means that they would then not get accommodations in exams like extra time or someone reading out the questions or things that would support them. So they might say I don't want
对诸如自闭症没有全面的了解，这会影响他们对评估的看法，这是需要注意的一点。然后有些人会说，实际上等待时间太长了，我的孩子必须在此之前接受评估。例如，我认为你需要努力记住，我想是在一个人参加普通中等教育证书（GCSE）考试的两年前，他们必须已经确诊，以便在GCSE考试中获得任何便利措施。因此，对某些人来说，他们可能会注意到自己孩子身上的倾向，孩子可能在苦苦挣扎，而等待名单意味着他们在考试中将无法获得诸如额外时间、有人读题或能支持他们的东西等便利。所以他们可能会说，我不想
to wait that long or I can't wait that long, it's impact in well-being and they might choose to go privately instead or they might feel more confident in a private diagnosis being more holistic and so yes some people might choose then to go private and again you've got bigger companies that might do shorter and lower cost assessments and then you've got more kind of individuals that specialize in it that might do a more in-depth and kind of personalised assessment. It is worth thinking if people are wondering about medication, if you go for right to choose or private, sometimes that will be accepted by your GP. Sometimes it won't.
等那么久，或者我等不了那么久，这正在对幸福感造成影响，他们可能会选择转而寻求私立医疗，或者他们可能会对私立诊断更加全面更有信心，所以是的，有些人可能会选择去私立机构。而且你会发现，有一些较大的公司可能会提供较短且费用较低的评估，然后还有更多专注于此的个人，他们可能会提供更深入、更个性化的评估。如果人们在考虑药物治疗，值得思考的是，如果你选择“选择权”或私立途径，有时你的GP会接受这一点。有时则不会。
Even if your GP says go with this provider from right to choose, they might then say we're not accepting shared care to pay for medication. But other GPs will take it. It's not an absolute no. So it is worth speaking. every GP has their own rules, they can make up their own rules of whether they accept shared care or not. So it literally varies. And sometimes people might have a diagnosis, their GP says, No, I won't accept shared care. And they ring up the other GP in their area 10 minutes down
即使你的GP说选择“选择权”途径的这个提供者，他们随后也可能会说我们不接受共享护理来支付药物费用。但其他GP会接受。这并不是绝对的不行。所以交流一下是值得的。每个GP都有自己的规则，他们可以制定自己的规则，决定是否接受共享护理。所以它真的因人而异。有时人们可能得到了诊断，他们的GP说，不，我不接受共享护理。然后他们给离他们10分钟路程的
the road, and they say, Oh, we do. And so they just swap GP surgeries. So sometimes it's as simple as, you know, kind of exploring in the area. But yeah, in terms of medication privately, you might be able to access a prescriber through the kind of so when we do assessments, we're on a prescriber pathway, which means our reports, any reports done within the practice are accepted to be of a quality standard and a prescriber will look and be able to prescribe medication. If you get medication privately again you might be able to then stabilise on a dose and go back to your GP and say will you take over shared care. There are lots of options, it is a
街区那头的另一个GP打电话，对方说，哦，我们接受。于是他们就直接更换了GP诊所。所以有时事情就像探索该地区的医疗机构一样简单。但是，是的，就私立药物治疗而言，你或许能够通过某种渠道接触到处方医生——所以当我们做评估时，我们处于处方医生的途径上，这意味着我们的报告、诊所内完成的任何报告都被认为达到了质量标准，处方医生会进行审查并能够开具药物。如果你通过私立途径获得了药物，你或许能够稳定剂量，然后回到你的GP那里问：“你们会接手共享护理吗？”有很多选择，这确实
bit confusing. Children's assessments tend to be better done face-to-face so I would recommend getting someone local who does it face to face rather than online for children's assessments, for adults assessments, it's okay to do online as long as they meet the other kind of guidelines. Thank you, that's really interesting, really helpful for people to kind of take on board and consider their options. I know, you know, it's probably quite a big question with perhaps quite a lot of range, but if someone's looking into, for example, a private ADHD assessment for an adult, is there some of a price range for that that people might be able to expect?
有点令人困惑。儿童评估往往最好是面对面进行，所以我建议为儿童评估找一个当地能面对面做的人，而不是在线评估；对于成人评估，只要他们符合其他相关指导方针，在线进行是可以的。谢谢你，这真的很有趣，对人们吸收并考虑各种选项非常有帮助。我知道，这可能是一个相当大的问题，或许涉及面很广，但如果有人正在寻找例如针对成年人的私立ADHD评估，人们可以预期的大致价格范围是多少？
I mean, yeah, but it does depend. It depends on how someone prices it. So there is quite a range sometimes in how long an assessment will take. If you go in depth with someone, if someone has had a lot of difficult life experiences or it's more complex, it's gonna be a longer assessment. So some people will price an ADHD assessment as a kind of a one-off fee.
我的意思是，是的，但这确实取决于具体情况。这取决于某个机构如何定价。因此，评估需要多长时间往往有相当大的差异。如果你与某人进行深入评估，如果某人有许多困难的生活经历或者情况更复杂，这将是一次更长时间的评估。所以有些人会将ADHD评估定价为一个一次性费用。
They might say, okay, it's a thousand pound or it's 1500 pounds or you know, kind of, you might get a one-off kind of bulk price. Other people might say it depends on the length of the assessment. So within our practice, we do it by an hourly rate because that means that for some people, otherwise they will be paying a high fee and they're not requiring that amount of time. It feels really unfair for them. So it's actually done much more on how long does this actually take and we're kind of charging you a fair rate based on that. So therefore it could fluctuate. But yeah, approximately, I think some of the bigger companies that were doing a
他们可能会说，好吧，这是一千英镑，或者一千五百英镑，或者你会得到一个一次性的打包价格。其他人可能会说这取决于评估的时长。在我们的诊所，我们按小时收费，这意味着对某些人来说，否则他们将支付高昂的费用，而他们并不需要那么多时间。这让他们觉得很不公平。所以实际上它更多地取决于这究竟需要多长时间，我们根据这个向你收取公平的费用。因此它可能会有波动。但是，是的，大致来说，我认为一些规模较大的公司提供
faster assessment and they might not be a psychologist or psychiatrist, they might be a kind of someone who's just doing assessments. I think you can get them probably from about 500. For most people who are going to a psychologist or a psychiatrist, you would be expecting 1000, 1500 more kind of rate and sometimes higher than that. Again, higher if you're doing a combined assessment. So if someone is assessing for autism too, it's going to take longer. And an autism assessment must be done with two, an MDT, some multidisciplinary routine. There must be two professionals doing that, which means obviously there's a higher cost to do that. But yes, that's a kind of ballpark figure.
更快速的评估，他们可能不是心理学家或精神科医生，而可能只是从事评估工作的人员。我想你大概可以从500英镑左右开始获得这项服务。对于大多数去看心理学家或精神科医生的人来说，你会预计费用在1000到1500英镑甚至更高，有时还会更高。同样，如果你做的是综合评估，费用会更高。因此，如果有人同时评估自闭症，就会需要更长的时间。而且自闭症评估必须由两个人（一个多学科团队，即MDT流程）共同完成。必须有两名专业人员参与，这意味着这样做显然会有更高的成本。不过是的，这算是一个大致的估价范围。
And, you know, I wouldn't be hosting the Aspiring Psychologist podcast if I wasn't advocating for qualified, regulated, fully kind of professional, indemnified, experienced clinicians. And so I do think there's so much to gain by going for what seems like a slightly higher price, but you're getting that experience and you're getting that ability to kind of look across the lifespan, holistically drawing in all those different possible hypotheses and situations and clinical or non-clinical presentations. So just to advocate for the qualified regulated providers such as yourself, Kara. Yeah, and I think it's really important that somebody also, you know, part of an ADHD assessment is also being able to kind of
而且，你知道的，如果我不是在倡导合格的、受监管的、完全专业的、有职业责任险的、有经验的临床医生，我就不会主持“有抱负的心理学家播客”（Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）。因此我确实认为，选择看起来价格稍高但能获得那种经验、能够跨越生命周期全面审视、综合吸纳所有这些不同可能的假设与情境以及临床或非临床表现的服务，会带来巨大的收益。因此，我仅代表你这样的合格受监管服务提供者发声，卡拉（Kara）。是的，我认为非常重要的一点是，有人参与的ADHD评估也是能够
something called differential diagnosis, like look at, does this best fit with an anxiety presentation? Does it best fit with bipolar presentation? Does it best fit with ADHD? Or like what else could this be and what are the other possible explanations? And the problem with some people who aren't qualified and don't have that experience in other areas
进行所谓的鉴别诊断，比如观察：这是否最符合焦虑的表现？这是否最符合双相情感障碍的表现？这是否最符合ADHD的表现？或者这还可能是什么，其他可能的解释是什么？那些不具备资格、在其他领域没有丰富经验的人所带来的问题
is also that sometimes they then go, I think this is ADHD, I think this is anxiety, for example. And what we have a lot is that people come to us saying, we've been dismissed by another practice because they didn't really listen or they didn't really know how ADHD presents in people who are kind of higher functioning or in that kind of more female presentation or that more inattentive. So people have been completely dismissed and at the end of it, they're like, well, someone saw me for half an hour and they said no, but they didn't even ask the questions. Or so you might have spent £500 to be told no when actually it hasn't even been fully explored to really understand what's going on. There have been occasions I've done an assessment on like, oh, this doesn't feel quite so kind of in line with what I expect with ADHD.
还在于，有时他们会直接说：“我认为这是ADHD，我认为这是焦虑，”比如这样。我们经常遇到这种情况，人们来到我们这里说：“我们被另一家诊所拒绝了，因为他们没有真正倾听，或者他们并不真正了解ADHD在那些功能较高的人群中，或者在女性表现形式中，或注意力不集中表现形式中的表现。”所以人们完全被敷衍了事，到最后他们会觉得：“好吧，有人看了我半小时然后说‘没有’，但他们甚至都没有问问题。”或者你可能花了500英镑却被告知“没有”，而实际上甚至都没有对真实情况进行充分的探索以真正理解发生了什么。曾有几次我做评估时觉得：“哦，这感觉不太符合我对ADHD的预期。”
And then I hear more and more of kind of autistic type traits coming along. And I'm like, that has that has mastered that also. But as a psychologist, you're formulating and you're like, does this make sense when I've got all of the information? Someone who doesn't get all of the information, hasn't got the experience in formulating that I might miss it. And people can then end up feeling really, you know, kind of if they're sure they have ADHD and they're told no when they do, actually that can be a really unhelpful experience and you know, costly to then have to pay twice. Yeah, absolutely. We don't want people to be in a position where they're having to pay twice to get the service that they need and deserve. Cara, are there any common misconceptions about ADHD and adults?
然后我听到越来越多的自闭症类型的特质出现，我就想：这也有那种特质。但作为一名心理学家，你在进行病例构形（formulation），你会想：当我掌握了所有信息时，这说得通吗？一个没有掌握所有信息、没有构形经验的人可能会漏掉这一点。结果人们最终会感到非常，你知道的，如果他们确信自己有ADHD却被告知没有（而他们其实有），这实际上可能是一种非常糟糕的体验，而且还要花钱再去测第二次，这代价很高。是的，绝对如此。我们不希望人们陷入不得不花两次钱来获得他们需要且应得的服务的境地。卡拉，关于成人ADHD，有什么常见的误解吗？
Well, I guess you've got the whole kind of, at the moment, lots of people are saying everyone has ADHD or is it being overdiagnosed? Or so I think there's something around people feeling that it's kind of friendly or it's a way to kind of access extra support. Or so I think there's some misconceptions from some people that it's a desirable thing to kind of have all, you know, that people are looking for it because of the kind of things they might get as a kind of support with it. I mean, I think
嗯，我想现在有很多类似这样的说法：目前很多人都在说“每个人都有ADHD”或者“它是不是被过度诊断了？”或者我认为人们会觉得这是一种很友好的东西，或者是一种获得额外支持的途径。或者我认为有些人存在一些误解，觉得拥有它是一件令人向往的事，或者你知道的，人们寻找它是为了能够通过它获得某种支持。我的意思是，我认为
that's, I think most people you speak to with ADHD would say that even if there are massive strengths associated with it, which there are for some people, being able to hyper focus, being able to lean into your passion like it has great strengths, but at the same time, I think most people would say the reason that they're seeking an assessment is because it's had an impact, whether that is on their functioning, whether it's on their self-esteem, whether it's how they viewed themselves, whether it's the comments made by others or so. I think this idea that people would want to do it or it's desirable I think is a massive misconception. Most people are finding it hard and you know finding that
大多数跟患有ADHD的人交谈过的人都会说，即使与之相关联有着巨大的优势（对某些人来说确实如此），比如能够高度集中注意力（hyper focus），能够投入到你的热情中去——它有巨大的优势，但与此同时，我想大多数人都会说，他们寻求评估的原因是因为它产生了影响，无论是对他们的功能，对他们的自尊，还是对他们如何看待自己，亦或是其他人所说的话。所以，我认为这种“人们会想要这样做”或者“它是令人向往的”的想法是一个巨大的误解。大多数人觉得这很艰难，并且
difficult so those kind of comments are really tough. I think one of the things I notice around kind of medication is for people who are quite perfectionistic in you know doing whirling kinding roles that they're in, even if they're under the surface feeling this imposter syndrome. A lot of people think that medication will almost take away the symptoms. And I think a lot of people don't have so much of an understanding of the medication might help initially with increasing productivity and all of those things. But actually, it can also lead someone to be more likely to burn out in that if they are already
觉得很痛苦，所以那种评论真的很伤人。我认为我注意到的关于药物治疗的一件事情是，对于那些在他们所处的快节奏角色中表现得相当完美主义的人来说，即使他们在表面下感受到了这种冒名顶替综合征（imposter syndrome）。许多人认为药物几乎会消除症状。而且我认为很多人并不那么理解药物最初可能有助于提高生产力和所有这些事情。但实际上，这也可能导致某人更容易精疲力竭，因为如果他们已经
pretty productive and they lean into being more and more productive, people can be overly productive. And actually, they can struggle as a result of well-being. So I think sometimes as well, when you're kind of there's a misconception around medication is the way to go, well, this I need to do I need to be more productive when actually for someone they might not need to be more productive they might need to be focusing more on well being and how do I conserve kind of energy levels or motivation or. Yeah, and I don't think people always talk about the downside of if you become too productive. Now is there a point at which there's a ceiling to that and there might be an impact? Yeah, absolutely. Very good considerations. I think people also worry that if they were
相当高效，并且倾向于变得越来越高效，人们可能会过度追求高产。而实际上，他们的幸福感可能会因此受挫。所以我也认为，有时当你面临围绕药物治疗的误解时，会觉得“这就是我该走的路，我需要变得更高产”，而实际上对某人而言，他们可能不需要变得更高产，他们可能需要更多地关注幸福感，以及我如何保持能量水平或动力等等。是的，而且我认为人们并不总是谈论如果你变得过于高产所带来的负面影响。现在，这种趋势是否存在一个天花板，并且可能会产生影响？是的，绝对如此。非常好的考量。我认为人们还担心，如果他们
to take medication that it would change them, that they'd be a different person. What do you think about that, Cara? Yeah, I've heard that a lot. People who who say I don't want to try medication because what if it changes me as a person or I mean I haven't spoken to someone who's tried medication who actually says that, who says I feel different. Some people will say that for a lot of people medication improves kind of emotional dysregulation like the kind of emotions being up and down but actually for some people it's the opposite. Some people find that they feel more dysregulated with it. But I don't think, I haven't spoken to anyone who says I feel different as a person.
服用药物，它会改变他们，让他们变成另一个人。你对此怎么看，卡拉？是的，我经常听到这种说法。有人说：“我不想尝试药物治疗，因为如果它改变了我这个人怎么办？”或者我的意思是，我还没有跟一个尝试过药物治疗并且真的这样说、说“我感觉自己变了”的人聊过。有些人会说，对很多人来说，药物治疗改善了情绪失调——比如情绪起伏不定的情况——但实际上对某些人来说恰恰相反。有些人发现用药后他们觉得情绪更失调了。但我不认为，我没有跟任何人聊过他们会说“我作为一个人的感觉变了”，
I don't feel like me or I, yeah, I feel so quick to kind of respond to other people now that, you know, that's a lot of people either find medication helpful or they say it wasn't nearly as helpful as I thought or there's the risk as I say of burnout of you know kind of overdoing it but I haven't I haven't really spoken to anybody who's tried medication and said no I don't feel like me anymore and I need to come off it so I think you're right that is a misconception really. That's really good to know. Thank you so much for your time today.
“我觉得自己不像我自己了”或者“我，是的，我现在对其他人的反应太快了，以至于，你知道的，很多人要么发现药物有帮助，要么他们说它并没有想象中那么有帮助，或者正如我所说，存在过度劳累导致精疲力竭的风险”，但我没有真正跟任何尝试过药物治疗并说“不，我觉得自己不再是我了，我需要停药”的人聊过。所以我觉得你是对的，那确实是一个误解。这真的很好了解。非常感谢你今天抽出时间。
Could you tell us where the best place for people to learn more about you and your work might be? Yeah, so I have a couple of different websites, but I will link in the, I'll send across to you to link in the notes, just my link tree, which takes people to the website, to free resources. I have a free Facebook group where I share kind of top tips. So everything is on the link tree. So I'll share that with you.
你能告诉大家，人们想要更多了解你和你的工作，最好的去处可能是哪里吗？是的，我有几个不同的网站，但我会把链接放在，我会发给你把它放在说明栏里，仅仅是我的Linktree（链接树），它能把人们带到网站、免费资源。我有一个免费的Facebook群组，我在那里分享一些顶级小贴士。所以一切都在Linktree上。所以我会在稍后分享给你。
It is in the name of Dr. Davie ADHD coaching. But yes, feel free to kind of reach out if we can help you further. Amazing. Thank you so much for your time and sharing your absolute nuggets of wisdom with our audience. You are very welcome. Thank you for inviting me. You're welcome. See you soon. Bye. Bye.
它的名字是Dr. Davie ADHD coaching（戴维博士ADHD教练）。但是，是的，如果我们能进一步帮助到你，请随时联系我们。太棒了。非常感谢你抽出时间与我们的听众分享你的智慧结晶。不用客气。谢谢你邀请我。不客气。再见。拜拜。
Oh, thank you so much for watching and thank you again to my guest, the lovely Dr. Carla Davy. I hope you found it helpful. If you have, I would love it if you would rate and review the show, follow the show, like, subscribe, comment, share the content with people who you think it might also help. That really is the kindest thing you can do for any creator that you rate. Please do go and follow Kara on her socials or check out her link tree as she mentioned. The books we mentioned in that challenge were my first book, The Grief Collective, Stories of Life, Loss and Learning to Heal,
哦，非常感谢大家的观看，也要再次感谢我的嘉宾——可爱的卡拉·戴维（Carla Davy）博士。希望你觉得这期节目很有帮助。如果是这样的话，我希望你能为节目打分并撰写评论，关注节目，点赞、订阅、评论，并将内容分享给你认为也可能从中受益的人。对任何你欣赏的创作者来说，这真的是你能做的最善良的事。请务必去关注卡拉的社交媒体，或者像她提到那样查看她的Linktree。我们在那个挑战中提到的书是我的第一本书《悲伤集体：生命、失落与学会治愈的故事》（The Grief Collective, Stories of Life, Loss and Learning to Heal），
and Kara's book, There's a Rainbow Baby in My Mummy's Tummy, is a resource to help young children who've experienced the stillborn or late miscarriage loss of a sibling, and then there's a new pregnancy around and it's to help children understand what has happened and hopefully to feel more confident and hopeful for a happier outcome in future.
以及卡拉的书《我妈妈肚子里有一只彩虹宝宝》（There's a Rainbow Baby in My Mummy's Tummy），这是一本旨在帮助经历过死产或晚期流产失去兄弟姐妹的幼童的资源读物，当时正值有新生命孕育，旨在帮助孩子们理解发生了什么，并有望对未来的更好结果感到更加自信和充满希望。
It's a lovely book and it gets great reviews. So please do check out that book and The Grief Collective in the description or show notes, if you think either or both of those might be helpful to you or someone you are working with. It's the aspiring psychologist Poshkets With Dr. Mary Endrit There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一本可爱的书，获得了很好的评价。因此，如果你认为这两本书中的一本或两本对你或你正在合作的人有所帮助，请务必在简介或节目说明中查看那本书以及《悲伤集体》。这里是玛丽·安德里特博士（Dr. Mary Endrit）主持的“有抱负的心理学家播客”（The Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。